je sais que le genre j'ai d'abord à un
énorme cadeau gentils hommes à la voix
grave
michel dumont était un monstre sacré du
théâtre québécois trois ans dans son
décès il ne voulait rien savoir de la
retraite j'ai encore le goût de faire
c'est de m'occuper d'aller au théâtre de
voir du théâtre traduits
c'est michel dumont est ce que c'est
aussi votre première expérience comme
maintenant la première expérience comme
metteur en scène originaire du saguenay
michel dumont s'est d'abord fait
remarquer au théâtre jean-duceppe du
confit en 1973 le rôle de biff loman
dans la pièce la mort d'un commis
voyageur
les noms de jean duceppe et michel
dumont ils deviendront alors une social
c'est une perte terrible c'est la tête
aussi de toute heure tout un passé tout
un historique tout de tout acteur en
plus de multiplier les rôles le comédien
a pris la barre de la compagnie jean
duceppe
en 1991 il restera 27 ans il aura à
coeur de faire découvrir de grands
auteurs comme chez cob lui si le théâtre
québécois duras et 27 16 ans elle est
vraiment dans une place prépondérante à
la création québécoise a joué pour cinq
viols mais celle liée à jouer pour se
livrer quelque chose pour essayer un
petit peu de changer le monde ceci
bon ben là dessus moi je retourne à la
maison à la télévision michel dumont
était inoubliable dans une dame de coeur
dans marilyn dans providence et plus
récemment dans yamaska
je pense que michel cesser la génération
de de l'acteur nord-américain ans en
soutenant un grand gosse est un costaud
y assumer sa présence y avait une voix
quand il rentrait quelque part michel
avait toute une présence des gens vont
porter un jugement le public aussi je
comprends la noce de sa mort à 79 ans a
provoqué une onde de choc
décidément le monde de la culture par un
de ses grand bayern auto qui vont
prendre la relève mais il y en aura plus
comme michel dubos son legs fut d'abord
été un homme extrêmement intègre à tout
ce qu'il faisait
nationaliste passionné par la culture
québécoise
michel dumont a été jusqu'à la fin
habité par la rigueur et par l'amour du
public et le
grand moto de jean duceppe qui comme
c'était le mien tout le temps c'est
respecter le public radio canada bon